i'm off the grid for august but by golly
cnn did something actually sane
let me ask you another question it's
important for uh for all americans but
especially in texas the governor of
texas greg abbott says texas has now
bust nearly a thousand undocumented
migrants from the border in texas to new
york city in the last two weeks there's
an immigration researcher at syracuse
who said that abbott is doing these
migrants these undocumented individuals
a favor and quote practically ensuring
that these migrants will be allowed to
stay in the country because immigration
judges in new york tend to be more
lenient than immigration judges
in texas what do you make of this
stunt this move whatever you want to
call it by abbott
well look what he's doing is he's
sending a message
there's no secret there right this isn't
a policy move this is this is a move of
desperation to get someone to pay
attention to what we're dealing with in
texas you know which is why i support it
yeah
will they have a more likely likelihood
of staying in the country look basically
everyone is crossing our border has that
same likelihood there's millions upon
there's almost two million i think we're
at apprehensions just this year that's
an unprecedented number huge amount of
those will stay in the country because
the backlogs in our system are so severe
that that's going to happen anyway and
we're talking about the new york and dc
busing we're talking about a few
thousand immigrants that's what we deal
with on a daily basis in south texas so
look what he's doing i think is out of
desperation and it's highly necessary
because if somebody has to solve this
problem this is this is an infringement
on our sovereignty it's an infringement
on our rule of law and you know what
it's it's it's unfair and it's immoral
to the millions upon millions of good
law-abiding immigrants or asylum seekers
around the world that have no chance of
getting into our system because of the
backlog that that people are creating
because they're geographically close to
the united states and they can just walk
across it's not fair